- On this episode, my dear
friend and business partner,
Matt Higgins, stops by.
Also, he's about to be a shark.
(groovy music)
Hey everybody, this is Gary Vaynerchuk,
and this is episode 297
of the #AskGaryVee Show,
and I'm super excited, because,
has AJ been on this show?
No, alright, so this is literally,
probably the person I'm most closest to
that I've ever done a show with,
my business partner over the last decade.
We'll get into that in a minute,
but Matt Higgins is here.
Couple of things that are
exciting about this episode.
Number one, he looks better
than ever, which makes sense,
'cause he's on this
incredible publicity spree,
because he is now a shark on one
of the most famous shows
in business, period.
You're wearing shark socks, I see it Matt,
Guest star of Shark Tank this
year, very much well deserved.
I'm gonna let him tell
you his origin story,
'cause that's what we do
with every guest here,
but it interwinds very much
with my career as well,
and I think a lot of you will enjoy it,
and really where I wanna
go, because we're both here,
I think knowing my audience,
I wanna do as many calls as possible,
which is something we
haven't been doing as much.
So, I'm gonna let Matt kind
of establish comic book
number one, tell his origin story.
Then I'll throw out a couple questions,
and then we'll get into the phone calls.
So, Facebook, I know you're
watching live right now,
put in your phone call and your question,
especially as Matt
starts telling his story.
I think it will make sense.
Matt, how are you?
- I'm doin' great.
- Good to see you buddy.
- Thanks for havin' me, Gary.
- You're lookin' great.
- Cool.
- Awesome.
- Take it away.
- Alright.
- [Gary] Who are you?
- Who am I?
- Yes.
- Like, grew up, the whole bit?
- I tend to like those things.
- Alright, I grew up in Bayside, Queens,
on Springfield Boulevard.
Born at Flushing hospital.
Hustled in Queens my whole early
life, first job McDonald's,
actually, first, first job
selling flowers on the street,
second job McDonald's.
I grew up real poor, taken care of my,
you know this, I'm telling
it to you like you don't.
- I don't, I do not know.
- And, yeah I grew up, single
mother, who was amazing,
and takin' care of four
miserable boys, and,
- And what boy were you?
- I was the youngest.
Sometimes, shit rolls downhill,
so it landed in my lap,
but grew up really poor.
I know everybody says that,
but government cheese in the refrigerator,
and you know the whole bit,
church pantries on Sunday.
And my mother was amazing
and always tryin' to get ahead in life,
but everything for me was
about how do I get out
of this situation as
quickly as humanly possible.
And as you,
- How quickly did you
figure that out you think?
Like what, now when you reconcile that,
it's been interesting
to me how many things
I've realized about myself
as I've talked about myself,
done speeches, things of that nature,
attention was the big one.
Like, holy crap, I didn't
run lemonade stands,
I watched cars to watch people, holy crap,
I wasted the, wasted the first
three hours of baseball card
show to watch what people are
doing with their attention.
That is something I didn't
know till four, five,
or six years ago.
Now that you're talking about your career
and things of that nature,
when do you think you,
at this point right this
minute, when do you think
you woke up and said holy
crap, I gotta get outta this?
- I think when I was 10 years old.
I remember, ah, like something
happened where it seemed like
really desperate and had
an epiphany that if things
don't go in a different direction
they're not gonna end well.
And I remember--
- What year were you born?
- I was 1974.
- Got it.
So in '84--
- 84--
- Okay.
- I, a bunch of things
happened in my mother's life,
you know, she was sick--
- Like well--
- She was very depressed and just sick.
- Did she date other guys?
- No, no, we grew up--
- That's interesting.
- Yeah it's interesting you ask that.
Yeah, we were kind of a
unit and for some reason
around that time, I remember
I had been in a bus accident
and I was standing at the
ocean looking at the waves
thinking okay, this is not gonna end well.
And I kind of, I think that
was the beginning of me
being a little bit of a
loner and deciding like,
I need to figure out a
way out of this situation.
- And when you say a loner, do you,
this is just an interesting question.
I mean, we, this is what's fun about this.
I've never really gone
into these places with you.
- I'm getting uncomfortable.
- I know, you should because
I'm about to go there.
(Matt laughs)
Loner as in like, okay, not
that I don't want to be like
my brothers, but when you're
number four, and I'm listening
and I've never thought about it this way,
but we're putting on a show here.
You wanted to be on the show, here you go.
Do you mean loner, like, and
by the way, it's interesting
'cause I have a version of this too.
Which is like, and I've (knocks
purposefully) had such good
things that I'm dealing, it's
just like, sometimes you go
inside of your head--
- Yeah, actually I've never
thought about what do I mean
by that word, but now I do.
We used to go to the
emergency room all the time
for healthcare 'cause we had nothing,
and that became kind of our
doctor, and it's the time
when I started realizing
that these were intractable
problems, you don't use
the word attend but like,
there's no answer to this.
And that you have to kind of
take matters into your own
hands, not like I had the answers at 10,
but I definitely had the problem at 10.
- [Gary] Yes.
- And then something happened,
back to pattern recognition.
When I was a kid, my
mother actually got a GED
as an adult.
And she was able to go to college.
She did really well.
And around the time I was in eighth grade,
I said wait a second.
If she was able to go
to college as an adult,
kinda by accident, if
I did this on purpose,
then I could get out of
this situation even faster.
- So she, so listen.
I grew up at the same
time as you did and school
became a gateway out.
- Yeah, school became a gateway
out, but I also unnecessary.
Like, it just didn't add up.
Like, okay, I have a
desperate circumstance,
we're very poor, we need to move quickly,
she's getting progressively sicker, right?
And then there's this side
path which is if you actually
drop out at 16 and do well
enough, you can go to college.
So that was probably the
first most unconventional
decision that I ever made, that
everybody said you're crazy
like, you're throwing it away.
And when I say loner, it's the,
when I started to cultivate
this voice in my head
like hey, wait a minute,
I have a plan and I don't need
anybody else to agree to it
because they're not
looking at the apartment.
- They don't have context.
You always say all the time, which I love,
nobody had a window.
First of all, when you're a
kid, you're trying to wear
Jordash Jeans or Guess.
I'm dating myself, right?
(Gary laughing)
You're doing everything you
can to conceal your shame.
- [Gary] Sure.
- So, everybody was saying
you're insane to drop out
of high school, I was
like no, you don't know
what you're talking about.
Now when I made the move and I dropped out
of Cazorla High School at
16 and I was like okay,
now you gotta--
- Which is so, right now if
people drop out of high school,
like in 2018, 2019,
and they've got a plan?
There's a level of like oh,
that might be an entrepreneur
that's gonna go do something.
When you and I were growing
up, anybody that dropped out
of high school was 100% certified loser.
- Oh forget about it, right.
And that's funny, I remember when I--
- Like, you even just went
back to New York Talk,
just forget about it.
- Oh no, when I,
when I, did I say forget--
- It like set you back,
(men laughing)
that was the most Queensy thing--
- No I have Queens--
- I've been hanging,
that was the most Queensy,
like, it literally just,
that moment just put you back in there.
- So, I remember, or now
I'm gonna take it real.
I remember sitting on the
steps, first of all you have to
return all your textbooks when
you drop out of high school.
Back then, at least.
So you have to go class to class.
And I remember walking into
my science teacher's class,
Mr. Rosenthaw if you're
out there, it stuck,
and I went to bring back my
textbook and he goes, like,
Higgins, what a shame, what a waste.
And he goes, I remember
he told me, I'll see you
at McDonald's, at the time
I did work at McDonald's.
I said well, if you see me at
McDonald's because I own it,
that was all talk.
I went out, sat on the steps
of Cardoza, smoked a butt
'cause now I was gonna get
picked up by the truant police
at that point, and I thought damn.
Like, that was a balsy move.
- And so what happened next?
- I executed.
- Okay.
- I said, I--
- So what did you do?
- I know I'm right.
I went, I started taking
GED classes for like a week,
and I was like alright,
this is not for me.
You're allowed to take it
on standby, if you show up.
I went to Springfield Gardens
High School in Queens,
I went on standby, took
my GED, took the SAT's
a couple of weeks later, and
within three months I enrolled
in Queens College at 16.
- Okay.
- Then, just to prove a
point, went back to my prom
at high school as president
of the debate team,
and I was like how do
you like them apples,
to date myself.
(Matt laughing)
So, to me that's probably one
of the most important things
that's ever happened in my life.
Because, everything you talk
about, you don't have context
so I'm not gonna listen to
you because your opinion
doesn't matter 'cause you
don't have the full story.
- I mean, that is just--
- Right?
- I have a plan.
And if I have a plan and
I believe in the plan,
that's more important than
anything else that's going on,
right?
- Sure.
- And, I have pattern
recognition skills that maybe
set me apart.
So, trust in them, right,
that they can get you
where you want to go.
And your point about how you get judged
about being a dropout?
I knew that I'm gonna have
to make sure that the rest
of the track record can
overcome that one decision.
- Well, it's like being
a sixth round pick.
- [Matt] Right.
- You're judged for
being a sixth round pick
until you go to the Hall of Fame.
- Exactly, well, it's funny you said,
like law school is my Hall of Fame.
'Cause I was like this,
okay, I'll go to law school--
- Makes sense.
- I'll do is, I was in law
review, top in the class,
whatever, I went through
four years of law school
at night, and as soon as I
graduated, I never even took
the bar, I said okay,
well I cleaned that up.
- And then what happened?
- Well, all in between
my career was taking off.
So, because I dropped out
early, got great jobs early.
- Like what?
Like I actually--
- You don't know?
So--
- No.
- While I was doing that,
I was working as a reporter
for the Queens Tribune
and people would send me their problems.
I created a little column
called The Trib Action Desk,
and they would send me
their problems about things
they were do, and they
were mundane issues.
But I would take the mundane
and make it very interesting.
You know, some guy in Hamilton
Beach, Queens and the city
had built a bridge next to
his house and the bridge
had started destroying the
foundation and he had an animal
menagerie, and it ended up
blowing up in New York papers.
Like, things like, I would
take these crazy stories,
I'd drive around in my
little Nissan Maxima
with the broken radiator
like, all night long--
- And who took note of that--
- Uh, a lot of different reporters.
Daily News did a big profile on me,
called me a real action hero.
And it started happening.
Started happening.
And then ultimately,
Mayor Giuliani gave me my first big job.
- What were you doing before Giuliani?
- I was doing doing the--
- Didn't you do like a
.com thing, like Kozmo?
- That was in between.
- [Gary] Yeah, what was that?
- Um, Kozmo.com.
- Yeah, Kozmo, yeah.
- [Matt] Still amazing.
- [Gary] You worth a trillion dollars--
- I was worth a trillion,
I mean, it was amazing,
I was so rich.
10,000 options.
- Help me right here.
'Cause this is where all the
kids, like, I just can't wait
for the world to melt, as you know.
- I don't like when you say that.
- I know, you get worried.
- We own this together.
- I know, but like, I'm very--
- I'm still, I still have like PTSD--
- Yes, I know, but I'm ready.
- The mattress.
Yeah, weirdly--
- 'Cause I'm in the trenches.
- [Matt] Well, I think you
just want to get back there.
- I'm like, no no.
I don't use it.
I want to navigate the storm.
- Yeah, you like the big reveal.
I'm done with the big reveal.
- No, I get it, but here's the
good news in this scenario.
You got your own other
things, but you'll be able
to watch, I'll be like
this head right here,
watch this!
- Here, watch that, alright.
- You know, right now a lot
of kids are either doing well,
I was at a conference
yesterday and I talked
where it's a lot of
videographers, a lot of vloggers,
a lot of influencers, I'm
like guys, you do understand
the $39000 you're making
this year in brand deals
on Instagram photos goes away
when the economy gets tight?
Because, Coca-Cola gets tight.
- It's cruel of you to
tell 'em it's happening.
- No, it's the single best
thing I can do, right?
Because everybody's
living in fantasy land.
- [Matt] That's true.
- You lived in fantasy
land with your Kozmo stock,
and already thought about
what was gonna happen
and it all went to dead zero.
- Well, that's what I was
about to, I learned something
with Kosmo--
- [Gary] That's good.
Teach, teach, Matt.
- That was so important.
So I got to Kos, okay I will.
Kozmo, one of the biggest
internet companies at the time
raised 300 million dollars in 1998.
It would deliver everything
to you in under--
- Listen, Andy.
- Deliver everything to
you in under an hour.
It was actually an amazing company.
- [Gary] Yeah, last mile.
- Last mile, 10 thousand
employees, 10 cities--
- By the way, here we are 20 years later,
still no last mile.
- Still no last mile.
- Another thing people need to learn.
- And interesting that the
business could have been
profitable at an average order
of $24, 2.5 orders per hour,
and there was no smart
phone making those orders.
- That's right.
- That's just, anyway,
it's burned into my head.
But what was interesting,
the signs were everywhere
towards the end.
And I remember thinking we got,
somebody joined the company
as our CFO at the time and he had huge--
- And what were you doing?
- I was Director of Comms.
- [Gary] Keep going.
- So I did the road show, the whole thing.
So this, I won't say who
the person was but they quit
this massive job at a moment
when I'm saying the signs
are everywhere that
we're about to go under,
and was completely seduced by--
- The upside of the equity.
- And here I am, Giuliani
offers me a chance to become
the youngest Press Secretary
in New York City history
for which I'd have to leave my
trillion dollars of options.
And I had to--
- None of it was vested?
- Well no, none if it was vested, right?
It was sort of locked up.
But I had to make, okay,
here's this person who's got
this huge job making this
decision to join the company
at the exact moment we're
only weeks away from total
imminent decline, and yet I
have to decide to walk away.
And I made the right choice.
I made more money selling
the gear on eBay, you know,
that I did at the
company with the options.
But the point of that story
is trust your instincts.
Like, don't outsource
your judgment to somebody
who has less facts.
- What was the max value of
all those stocks on paper?
- I'm in a few million
dollars at this point.
But I never tried to get too
close to it because it never
happened--
- But that was like, you know.
- No, I won!
I was rich!
- And then went to zero.
- [Matt] Yeah, went to zero.
- It's gonna happen to
so many people soon.
Oh, it's gonna be interesting.
What's interesting about
the collapse of 01 and 07
was there wasn't a
majority of social media.
What I'm unbelievably worried
about, and why I keep talking
about it and why I will
continue talking about it
basically everyday, is
we have a bunch of people
that are posturing of success
on Instagram and Facebook
and Twitter every single
day, and they're all,
and 99% are gonna lose 'cause
they're over-leveraged,
which means they're gonna
have to deal with the fact
of that judgment at scale.
Like, you weren't posting.
We can't look at your Twitter
from 2002 talking big game
at being at NoBu, right?
Because you had two million
in the bank as a 20 something
in stock, but that's what was happening.
- But do you think the
cycle's the same now?
- [Gary] 100%.
I remember companies were
getting funded Pets.com,
all this was about Lion Share?
- Yes, I do.
- Are people getting funded on My Share?
- I do believe people who
are claiming on Instagram
right now that they're
building the next supreme,
or the next Instagram, and
every picture during the summer
is in the Hamptons on a
swan when they go work
at Chase in two years because
they're out of business,
that's gonna hurt.
Yes I do, I think that is a problem.
- Okay, what are we gonna
do when that all collapses?
- Well, we're gonna make a
lot of money because we're
preparing for that and
are building a machine,
VaynerMedia's built in a
way, like all the margin
I don't deliver is predicated
on capturing the growth
when Poll and Springs goes
from 100 million to 29 million
dollar budget and they
have to make that work.
So, you know, but it's
not like I'm like he he he
being secretive, I'm
just, I'm telling people
what I'm doing.
My biggest advice always
to my audience is watch
what I'm doing, not what I'm
saying, because then you'll
really know what the hell is going on.
What's going on?
I'm eating crow running
this God damn company
because I know how fruitful
it will be when inevitably--
- And that's what I would say.
I always think the one thing
that you don't give enough
insight into is just how
hard you work as an operator,
how much you spend all your
time, and how right you are
on trends, business trends.
I've got one incredible
insight, not to blow your smoke,
but you are.
And from that first time
we met in the bagel store,
alright, that's when I said I like Gary.
- Why don't we tell that story I think?
So, let's go quickly, 'cause
I wanna get into some--
- Yeah, I get bored of the bio story.
- Juliana, you're with him
during 9/11, that's an episode
within itself, I mean, that
you should be putting content
about, you should put
it just for generations
in the future.
It's just interesting stuff.
Like, to be at the hip of
Mayor Giuliani during 9/11
is one of the unique lives, in America.
I don't know what else to say.
It's yours, thus it's
hard for you to see it.
I don't know how big
that team was or wasn't.
But you're talking about 40,
20, help me here, jump in,
19, 27, what was the core
circle of Team Giuliani on 9/11.
- That's probably yeah, 25 people.
I was doing--
- Think about that.
Out of 300 plus Americans who,
you know, there's some young
people who didn't, it's crazy
now to think about how many
people didn't, 9/11, what are
you talking, 17 years ago?
17 years ago, man, it's crazy
that 22 year olds don't know.
- Yeah, they don't, I--
- [Gary] Like, how old are you?
- [Josiah] 24.
- You know, like--
- [Matt] It starts to take on
a Pearl Harbor quality, right?
- You were here in America?
- No, I was in Houston.
How old are you?
But in Houston, I'm sorry, I wasn't sure.
Like, you were in America on 9/11.
- [Josiah] Yes, yes I was.
- What do you think about when I say 9/11?
Do you remember anything?
- [Josiah] Hardly anything.
- How old are you?
- [Dustin] 34.
- Man, you look great.
Brooke, how old are you?
(people laughing)
- [Brooke] I'm 22.
- 22, you don't--
- [Matt] Yeah, what do you--
- [Brooke] I remember it.
- But how?
- [Brooke] On the TV.
- But like, how?
For you, 9/11 is like--
- Is it like Pearl Harbor?
- It's like Vietnam.
- Or is it like Vietnam, or?
- It means nothing.
Like it meant something,
but you were five.
- [Brooke] My grandmother was
in the room, she's crying.
- Right, so that's what you remember.
- [Brooke] Yeah.
- But like, it's cra,
anyway, none the less,
for most of, like it's crazy
to think that you were so close
to probably the signature moment
of the majority of people's
lives in American History.
- Yeah, I was standing,
I was standing outside when
the first building collapsed.
Right, we were setting up to do,
one thing about Giuliani, he
handled a crisis by letting
everybody know that, you
know, it was under control
and that he was there.
- We got this.
- So, right before the first
tower collapsed, I was standing
outside setting up a press
conference so that he could do
what he normally would do,
which was say we've got this.
And then, it just was
so clear that this was,
this was a war zone.
This is unlike, but in the
beginning, you remember?
It wasn't clear.
- Yeah it was like a plane hit--
- The first report.
Plane hit, was it a Cesena?
And so for me, that began
a two year chapter, right?
Because I was there for that
moment, stayed with Giuliani
as Press Secretary managing
the global response
to the attack, which became
its own obligation, right?
How do we telegraph what happened here?
How do we enlist the support of the world?
And then, I became the first
employee of the rebuilding.
So I arrived with a cell
phone and a massive federal
budget with a group of
people to start rebuilding.
I spent two years of my life.
I moved down there, I would
sit on the roof of my building
on Chambers Street and write
speeches while everything
was still going on.
So, it was just basically,
that day really lasted
for two years.
That's why it's hard for
me to tell the story 'cause
it's still kind of a blur.
Like, I don't totally understand it.
I haven't gone back and
looked at all the footage
and understood the impact--
- And then what happened next?
- So I did two years, I decided
I was gonna see it through
until we had a design for the memorial
and the Freedom Tower
and then I transitioned
to the New York Jets.
- That's right.
- That's where I'm at--
- So how did that happen?
- The New York Jets were
looking for somebody to help
them build a stadium
because they never had one.
- That's here--
- Here, in New York.
- Literally, no, no.
Here.
- Oh yeah, here!
- Like literally here.
- [Matt] That's right, here.
- This Hudson Yard's project.
- [Matt] So we waged an epic, you know--
- Come to war.
- Yes, battle.
Spent, both sides, probably
100 million dollars
fighting, Cable Vision
went to war to stop it,
thank you.
- This is Gorgardon.
- Right, exactly.
So that lasted probably two years.
And, ultimately--
- How close did it get?
- It got really close.
We had a majority of the
City Council supporting it.
- Uh, for everybody who is
listening, this is obviously
very emotionally for me.
The Jets wanted to build--
- Yeah, for you.
- Way more for me than you.
I don't give a shit how involved you were.
Emotionally, way more than me.
- Way more, this part
is emotional for me.
- Fair enough, but we are
literally, literally the office
building we're in right now is in the spot
that was battled over in
the early 2000's about where
the New York Jets almost
built their stadium,
which would have been in Manhattan.
And as somebody who's a Jet's
fan in a town that is very
Giant's out, you can imagine
having the actual stadium
in Manhattan was
obviously very attractive.
Now I'm a Jersey boy and I
love that it's out there,
but it was an attractive
proposition being in Manhattan.
- And it was going to
be home to the Olympics.
- That's exactly right.
- Remember, and they killed
the Olympic bit.
- Right, of course.
- So, it's so hard to explain
the convoluted political
process but it was a war of television ads
ads and tens of thousands
of union representatives--
- Oh it was crazy.
- Fighting, it was crazy.
And I ran that fight.
And then, it died on
the steps of the capital
when Shelly Silver, who
is now going to jail--
- [Gary] Is that true?
- Yeah, yeah, Shelly's been
indicted, convicted, yeah,
well, see the bitterness lasts.
- Yes, yeah of course.
- That's okay,
I'm gonna hold onto it.
And we lost.
Right, and so then, and the
reason why the Jets chose me
is they needed somebody
who had that background
in the city politics--
- I get it.
- And whatnot.
- And what did you come in as?
- I come in as like VP of Strategy.
- [Gary] And then what?
- And every other job eventually ending up
as EVP of the business.
Running the business of the team, right?
- How long were you with the Jets?
- Eight years.
- Man, that's a real run.
- I started with the Jets
when I was probably 28?
- And Hafstra was headquarters,
well, headquarters
is in Manhattan, but--
- Well I was in Manhattan,
they were out in Hafstra,
and then--
- Right, you moved to Florida.
- Yeah, and then I ran that process.
Alright, so I ran the
process how to figure out
how to build a practice
facility in New Jersey
and then relocated in
New Jersey out of anger.
- And Matt, we met because what?
- We met because I was
trying to sell you a suite.
You were like, we have
this like pinup at the team
at the time, who could afford
a suite but isn't buying one?
- Right, Wine Library.
- Yeah, and you were like,
you know, you were target
number and that bagel store
was a target rich environment,
right, so I had to come out and see you.
- Such an unbelievable
story, really quick.
'Cause I want to get into
other parts of his career
about Matt, I wanna get
into the Shark Tank stuff--
- [Matt] No, I like telling this story.
- But, it, so go ahead.
- It's interesting, no because
it's the Genesis story.
- I'm running wine library,
this is as me and AJ
are planning VaynerMedia but no body knows
so I'm actively just running Wine Library.
I get an email from the Jets
which always gets responded to
right away, and the
President wants to meet you,
and I'm like hell yes,
and we went to Bagel Smith
on Springfield Ave in
Springfield, New Jersey, yes.
- That's right.
So I'm going to sell Gary a
suite, which is not something
that you love to do as an executive.
So, it's a hard thing to sort of sell.
I go to meet Gary, Jeff
Fernandez had asked us to do it,
and I go to meet Gary in a bagel store.
And in the first ten
minutes I'm listening to you
with your phonetic energy
and your predictions
and I didn't follow you on Wine Library.
But I always remember, I think
about the second ten minutes
right, 'cause that's when
all this magic happened.
Gary started telling all these
stories about how the world
was gonna unfold.
And to give you an example,
I started making predictions
that Matt, in another couple
of years, everything is gonna
be about social media and digital content,
but more importantly, content
is gonna be democratized.
And everybody is gonna become
their own content publisher.
And because of that, these
corporations are like big
battle ships, they're not
gonna be able to manage that
in house, they're never gonna
have enough sophistication
to figure out how to go
ahead and tap into that.
And there's gonna be a new
type of agency that'll be born
that will figure out how to manage that.
And I'm the guy to do it.
Interesting, sounds legit.
And my brother AJ and I,
as soon as he graduates
'cause he's 12, we're gonna
launch this big company
and I'm gonna be a billionaire,
I'm gonna buy the Jets.
You fucking tell everybody
I'm gonna buy the jets, right?
So you know, going back
to pattern recognition
smoking the butt in high school, right?
Over those years I started
trusting myself that when I see
a pattern playing out, and
I see somebody speaking
the truth that's got the
courage to get it right,
and it resonates with me, I
don't care if anybody else
in the world knows if
they're right or not.
So, within those second
ten minutes, I was like oh,
Gary is sitting in the stream
of information and data,
he's opening up himself to
the world and is starting
to see the patterns, and he's right.
And I don't know if you remember
too, you started predicting
I don't know, I think
Facebook is gonna be,
all the things that you--
- I wish I was recording
that meeting.
- [Matt] Yeah, no--
- It would look really
good on me right now.
- It really would.
So with that, and that's
why I tell everybody,
you know it's cliche, but you
know where the puck is going.
So at that meeting, we did a deal, right?
- [Gary] Yup.
- A couple things.
Take a Jet's player who
doesn't deserve to be famous,
and make him Twitter famous.
- [Gary] That's right.
- That was mission number one.
If you succeed, we'll give
you four Jet's tickets
to become the first client,
I know others claim this,
but I'm gonna claim I
am the first client--
- [Gary] Yes, yup.
- And two, make me the
guy in sports two gets it.
So, I can get a huge job, right?
(men laughing)
Total self dealage.
Check, check--
- And check.
- [Matt] And none of those early articles
do I credit Gary.
- No, should have.
- Which I think you
even framed one of them
so you give me shit about it, right?
- [Gary] Yes, I did.
- It was the journal article.
- Yes.
Matt Higgins master my social media rise
of the New York Jets.
And I'm reading it, it's
somewhere else else in here
nope, not in here.
- By the way, even in Fast
Company, I pulled up an article
today--
- I love it.
- But no, remember we had dinner in Chatum
with Kerry Rhodes,
- With Kerry Rhodes.
- Kerry Rhodes, Mr. Hollywood.
- One of my favorite players of all time.
- And you made him--
- Massive!
Kerry Rhodes, at one point,
was literally the second
or first most followed
football player as a safety
for the New York Jets on Twitter.
The Jets were the number
one team followed on Twitter
in 2009 and 10, period.
And so yeah, we did a lot of great work.
It was a lot of fun.
I remember my first meeting,
we had just drafted Sanchez,
and I was like I don't
need, like, sports marketing
is like market around the stars.
And I was like, I wanna
make the punter famous.
I wanna make the people
that cover coverage
on special teams, and I still
believe that to this day.
I still believe to this second
the biggest vulnerability
in sports marketing is
they give too much power
to the individual athlete and
the athlete should be doing
that, everybody should be doing
what they should be doing,
but anyway, it was a great run.
- But remember how hard it
was in those early days.
When you would get a cease and
decease letter from marketing
on Myspace--
- Of course.
- I think in 2009 I got a
cease and decease letter
from the NFL, like you're not
allowed to market on Myspace,
right, so it wasn't easy to go ahead.
- [Gary] No.
- And players were still
scrppling with am I allowed
to use Twitter?
- [Gary] 100%.
- I mean, actually, not even
grappling was even allowed,
right, so we were breaking
down walls back in the day.
- [Gary] We were, we were.
- To give ourselves credit.
- And then your career transitioned again.
And by the way, I don't
think I've ever told you
this story.
I came to a Jets practice
during pre-season
and you said hey, there's
something brewing in my career,
and I remember thinking--
- I remember thinking,
do you remember that?
- I remember it very well.
- [Matt] And we were
standing in the sun light.
- Uh huh, and I remember
thinking no, no, no, Matt.
I like you at the Jets.
- [Matt] Right, right.
- I like the Jets.
Yeah, don't leave.
But you were right.
- Yeah, no I like you.
I always had the desire
to be an entrepreneur.
And I had all those ideas that
were percolating in my head
and I think you reach
a tipping point, right?
At 2 o'clock in the morning
you're like oh, I can run this.
We were talking about
creating a fund together.
Gary's got all this great
insight, if only we could
monetize it.
Jessie Deris, our partner in
my PR firm, I knew that he
needed to be running his own firm.
Just all these ideas, and it just,
it reached a tipping point.
- How long did Ross, Steve
Ross, who now we're gonna
transition to over to Dolphins
who brought you on board,
how long was he courting
you as an executive?
Was that a quick courtship?
I don't know this story.
- Yeah, I think I had
made, I was going through
a lot of personal transitions in my life.
And I had made the decision like, okay,
if I don't transition out of this job,
I'm never gonna leave it.
Like, sometimes it's tough.
Like, when you have a job that
everybody in the world wants,
or a lot of people want,
it's very hard to listen
to your inner voice and say that's great
that this is the job you
want, but I've run my course--
- Yeah, but you're eight years.
- Yeah, eight years and if
the office on the 50 yard line
and the private plane and everything,
very hard to let that go.
So I made a decision I
was gonna transition.
And when that got out
there, that's when I started
to have conversations with Steve--
- [Gary] Different people.
- And Steve is a maverick.
- [Gary] Sure.
- I mean, he's sitting in
that room of NFL owners
and he's just of a different breed.
- [Gary] Yeah, no question.
- And he had all these ideas
that he wanted to pursue
around the team that resonated with me
and I had all these ideas
that I wanted to put to work
and he supported it, right?
In ways that are kind of
breath taking and including
becoming partners with
you and building this huge
international soccer
tournament that we have,
drone racing, and on and on.
But, that was six years
ago that we created RSC.
- So, to speed it up and then
we're gonna get into Q and A,
in the last six years
that you created RSC,
what are the highlights?
So you start this company
along with Steve--
- I start the company with Steve--
- You also become an executive
on the Dolphins side?
- Right, and--
- So you were an employee
on that side and executive?
- Yeah, so the oversee the
Dolphins on the business side,
put in place a great team,
but let it run itself--
- [Gary] Sure.
- And we have an amazing
CEO named Tom Garfinkle,
so that took care of itself.
- [Gary] Right.
- But let's build an
ecosystem around the team
that could either drive value
or extract value from, right?
So, some of the early deals,
you were on that first
power point, it's amazing
looking at my first pitch deck,
there were four ideas
and you were on that,
and look at where we are.
Jessie Deres was on that list.
Creating an international soccer business
was on that list 'cause we're in Miami.
Fast forward, we have the
largest soccer tournament
in the world.
And I remember sitting
with Steve at his desk
about three months in
going through the pitch
and he's like, that's a lot of stuff.
You sure you gonna do it?
I was like oh yeah, yeah,
you'll see, we'll do it.
So, since then what are the highlights?
I think seeing in somebody
something that maybe even they
don't see in themselves
yet and extracting it
and weaponizing it.
I love it.
- Matt, do you think that
Shark Tank, I'm jumping here
a little bit, put you on
because you've been so good
at picking entrepreneurs
and investing in them?
And when I look at, and
I feel like I am one,
but then I think that the
chapter that you've had recently
that's been more in the
food space, and I liked,
I think Jessie's a real maverick
of a young entrepreneur too
but the, when I look at what
you did with David Chang
or some of the, what you're doing in food
seems to be more of a pattern
of what you did with me
and then you did it
within a genre of food.
- [Matt] Yeah.
- Talk to me about that.
- So I think--
- Give people context.
The company invested
in whom what companies?
- Okay, so we're four spaces.
Sports and entertainment, drone racing,
international soccer, huge tournament.
Food and lifestyle, so we own,
we incubate a resie together.
David Chang is my partner,
Milk Bar, End Pizza,
Blue Stone Lane, a bunch
of different sort of large
fast casual companies and fine dining--
- When I look at the CEO of
Blue Star Stone, excuse me--
- [Matt] Yeah, Nick, yep.
- End Pizza, who's real amazing talent.
- [Matt] Amazing, yeah, Pizza Profit.
- These are, I mean, the Blue Stone guy,
but they're dynamic in all different ways.
- Yeah, they are.
So I think, you asked why
would Shark Tank want me on?
- [Gary] Yeah I mean--
- I think it's because--
- Because I know a lot of
entrepreneurs are watching
and when you're on this
season, I think it's super,
you know, it makes me,
I'm so happy you're on
because I think there's,
I think what they've done
with guests, weather it's
been Ashton or Sako or like,
they've gone for just Alex
Oregas, there's been a lot
of front-facing people.
- [Matt] Yeah, that's true.
- Right, you're disproportionately
least famous guest shark.
- Which I love.
I always say, my favorite comment,
I think I sent this to you.
When it was announced, somebody
commented on ABC's page
saying, but he only has 400 followers.
And I wrote back and I
said, 401 question mark.
That was like--
- That was almost
as good as when I was
on Planet of the Apps,
and the article was, and
on a new show Apple's first
original show, the guests
are, the judges are
Gwyneth Paltrow, Will I Am,
Jessica Alba, and others.
- And others.
(men laughing)
By the way, I'm showing up a
lot in the promos others too.
I decided not to be offended,
'cause now like you,
I'm starting to love the big reveal.
So why did they put me on?
I think my day job and my hobby
is helping people transcend
because I was that kid
that had all this potential
and then had to break
through in order to transcend
to what I was meant to be.
So for me, there's something
magical about unlocking
that butterfly that's in everybody.
- When you pick entrepre, I
apologize 'cause I'm looking
at the time and I want
to get some calls in.
- [Matt] Okay.
- So I apologize.
Let me give an insight to the
people that always get mad
at me for interrupting,
these are time slotted
unlike other people who's
entire life is being
a podcaster and they have
unlimited time and they do
post production, we slot them
in because we are busy peeps
and we have to stay within--
- And we do this to each
other all the time, so.
- That's true.
Matt, when you've been
wrong about entrepreneurs,
because you've been betting
on entrepreneurs over the last
half decade plus pretty
aggressively and it is now
becoming your brand, and I'm inevitably,
especially with the association with me,
especially with Shark Tank,
you are in for a decade
of people reaching out and
saying I'm the next David Chang.
Like, that's gonna be your life,
at least until you change it.
- [Matt] Right.
- It is very clear for
me from the outside,
because I think the thing
that people will be--
- [Matt] I like that life.
- Yeah, I mean, it's a
very interesting thing.
Like, I think one thing, even
if, I don't know if you guys
are picking up on this
nuance, and this is true
with my dad and my brother,
let alone a majority investor
into my company, the key
plug to the relationship.
Matt will tell you that
it is shocking how much
and how little we actually
talk business, right?
Like, everyone's so busy.
And I'm just the kind of
entrepreneur that's not
so detailed let's have
a meeting every month,
like review what's happening.
But what's, so I'm actually,
it's been fun for me
to watch you go through this
process the last 100 days
in anticipation of Shark
Tank, I'm like wow, you know,
it is very clear what Matt's
life is gonna look like
for the next half decade.
Which is, people are just
gonna pitch him left and right
of like, I'm the next entrepreneur
that you should be on.
So to that point, when you've been wrong
in the last six years, even
if it's not a bet you made
or you wanted to make
the bet and you didn't
'cause the price was too high
or they didn't take your money
and then you got to watch
him or her win or lose,
when you've been wrong, why do
you think you've been wrong?
- Number one reason,
minorities is number one.
Is when I thought that the
power of the idea would eclipse
whatever flaws were in the founder.
It's when I decided to overlook
the fact that the jockey
doesn't have what the takes,
and say well, the idea's
so good--
- The horse is so special.
- Yeah, every mistake,
I'm sure there are others.
Every mistake is always been--
- Oh I'm sure.
- Has been about the idea
we'll eclipse the founder.
And that's never true.
So it's always about the people.
- Do you, that's really
interesting you say that
because now that I was thinking
that might is what you said
because I've been very
intrigued by this chapter
in the food space because I
really, personally from afar
like the bets.
And I do think they're different
than the kind of things
you were looking at, 'cause
we looked at a lot of stuff
together when we had
Vayner RCR fund together.
I do think there's a maturity in the way
you're picking jockeys.
- Yeah, well I'm picking
special first, right?
I'm picking ideas that are
potentially scalable, right?
I don't wanna pick
something that could just be
a couple of units.
As you and I learned the hard
way, small ideas and big ideas
take the same amount of work.
It's an interesting secret of life, right?
You would assume there would
be a massive increase in work
to make a big idea, same
exact game, which is exciting
'cause that means you can keep
leveling up and do big stuff.
But um, I'm backing
special, backing scalable,
and backing people who have
the confidence and the humility
to make it work, right?
'Cause if you don't have
humility, you'll never pivot
and if you don't have confidence,
you'll never be comfortable
to have humility, right?
- [Gary] That's right, I
think that's somebody--
- Alright, we'll take some,
wanna take some calls?
- Yeah, we'll take some calls,
but I think that's right.
I think that contradiction
of confidence and humility
is something I talk a lot
about, I believe in it.
- Can I give a shout
out to my wife, Sarah?
That's alright.
- Is she the confidence or the humility?
- She's the whole package,
that's why I married her.
- [Gary] What are you?
- Uh, I'm only, I'm
inadequate, she back fields.
(Matt laughs)
(phone ringing)
- [Gary] Who's this?
Michael.
- [Michael] This is Michael.
- Michael, this is Gary Vaynerchuk,
you're on the AskGaryVee
show with Matt Higgins, how are you?
- [Michael] Outstanding, I
can't believe that I actually
got the call in.
Hey Matt, how's it going?
- I'm doing great.
Glad to hear you're outstanding.
(Michael chuckling)
- [Michael] So, my question--
- Go ahead, we're here.
- [Michael] Have known each
other for 34 years now--
- Hold on, hold on, brother.
You chopped off for a second.
Are you in a good spot,
what's his name again?
- [Producer] Michael.
- Michael, two things.
One, your voice scares the
shit out of everybody watching
when you were laughing,
it was a very evil laugh.
We're all very scared.
(Matt laughing)
But number two, you cut off
when you asked your question,
so ask it again, please.
- [Michael] So I said I was
a big fan of both you, Gary,
and I've known Matt for
about three four years now.
- Awesome.
- [Michael] So my question is for Matt.
When you acquire these companies,
or invest in these companies,
what are you looking at?
Are you looking for growth?
Are you looking for future sales?
What is your overall, as Gary would say,
your macro approach?
- Well, I'm a little different
from a firm or some PE shop
because I'm partnered with Steve Ross.
So the philosophy is we
don't worry about the exits.
The exits will be a by-product of success.
We don't force our founders to do that.
So we're looking for something
that can be an inherently
big business, maybe not in
the first Version 1.0 of me,
but certainly Version
3.0 now, a big business
and that there is an
inevitable path to exit
but we're not gonna focus on it, right?
So, a business that could
be sold that could exit,
but it's all about growth.
It's not about distributing
cash flow, it's not about,
you know, financial engineering
and you know, Excel sheets
as Gary says, it's just about growth.
- [Michael] Excellent.
And the final question
I have, and I know Matt,
a lot of questions, the final
question is how is the person
that runs probably, and owns
probably, one of the most
storied franchises of the
Dolphins partner with the most
(Gary laughing)
craziest Jets fan out there?
- Yeah, I've been looking to
sell our stake in the firm
for a long term so that answer
(Gary laughing)
is raising my profile to find a buyer.
We just don't talk about it.
I don't razzle him about it
'cause he's so emotionally--
- [Gary] Matt--
- I do not give him shit
because it's an area
I don't want to go to.
- And I don't say too much
either because one time
when I was getting on Ross
real heavy in a meeting,
he looked at me and said,
'You're a fan of the team,
"I own the team."
And that hurt.
- Yeah, that was pretty epic.
- I pretty much decided
that I would never
really go anywhere again.
He did to me what I like to do to others.
- [Producer] Yeah, sounds like--
- Yeah, yeah 100%.
- But you know, to give some
insight, so when we play
the Jets, Gary won't even come
over and say hello, right?
Like, you won't even--
- [Gary] That's right.
- It's like, when he
worked there, it just--
You're pretty, you won't
even shake our hands
in the sidelines.
- Yeah, Steve always goes, you're tribal.
He always yells at me, "You're tribal."
I mean, look, one of the
worst, if not the single worst
business decision in
my life, financially--
- [Matt] That I offered you.
- Yeah, yeah, Steve and Matt,
in our transaction of them
investing in Vayner, there
was equity in the Dolphins
offered and we went a different route.
We had the soccer idea,
then we did the fund,
but the multiple of the growth?
I mean, I lost tens of
billions of dollars in not,
by being a Jets fan.
- Big mistake as they
would say in Pretty Woman.
- [Michael] Well, I hope
to see you on the Jets.
Are you coming down for
the Jets Dolphins game?
- Yeah, I--
- Yeah!
- I'm not, I mean, I'm in
LA doing something I'm on
a red eye meeting right now.
I actually had that conversation today.
I would say very likely, yes.
- You go to almost--
- I guess he's never--
- I go to almost every one.
- Lost one with you, Matt,
right?
- Yes, of course.
Matt will be there.
- Absolutely.
- Thanks for calling, brother.
Thanks for calling.
Yeah, I mean, look, I think
that what's super interesting
about the jockey horse
conversation is that, like,
it is very clear to me, I
mean, I've not been doing
much investing, I mean we
did our fund, we, you know,
I've been very head down in
building the Vayner machine.
I think things are
over-valued in general for me
for early stage.
I think some of the later stuff
is a little more interesting
but the jockey is where I'm at.
- And I think the next phase
that you and I will go through
together is control.
- [Gary] 100%.
- If I'm backing Gary V directly--
- It's much more interesting
and a term sheet--
- So much more.
- To some monogamous company.
(phone ringing)
- 100%.
Like, I'm only into control now.
That's the whole macro
thing of Vayner, right?
(phone ringing)
Like where we buy brands
of the future, it's gonna
run through its all control.
Like, I don't want to guess.
- [Matt] Are we teasing
out our next move, or?
- I mean, I've been very public about it.
Nathan, it's Gary Vaynerchuk
you're on the AskGaryVee show
with Matt Higgins,
how are you?
- Hi, Nathan.
- [Nathan] Wow, what a freaking honor.
How are you guys?
- Good, Nathan.
- We're great!
- Where you from?
- [Nathan] Uh, I'm just mainly
calling because I wanted
some advice from two winners.
And what happened is
in the last year or so,
we kinda blown up on
Facebook Live Sports Cards,
and I've kinda gotten
a little overwhelmed.
We passed the five million
dollar mark and I'm starting
to have to handle employees
and things like that
and trying to take that next
step into that 10 million
dollar range in 2019 and I'm
just a little bit overwhelmed
trying to--
- And Nathan,
- Figure out.
- Nathan, do you, I just
want to start thinking
while you're talking.
Did you say a sports bar?
- [Nathan] A baseball card.
- Baseball cards?
- [Nathan] Yes.
- Okay, this is very exciting to me.
Matt, get out of here.
Hold on.
- [Matt] Doing five million
in revenue in baseball cards?
- So Nathan, real quick.
Where are you located?
- [Nathan] I'm in Murphryboro, Tennessee.
- Right, so we've interacted, right?
- [Nathan] That's correct.
- Cool, so this, you're the guy
I DM'ed with a bunch, right?
Like, you've grown a
lot at your retail store
in the last couple years, right?
- [Nathan] Correct, yes.
- On the back of social media
marketing advice, correct?
- [Nathan] Yes sir.
- Makes me super happy.
Okay, and so now you're
happening you're saying shit,
this is continuing to work,
and I can feel it going
to the next level and with
that comes new dynamics,
which is I'm not just
standing behind the counter
of my store and posting on social.
To the scale I'm at, I've
gotta bring in new employees
so now I'm getting two
more of an HR human game
not just being the marketer
and seller of '86, '87
Fleeter Basketball Cards.
- [Nathan] That's exactly right, yes.
- And so, do you hate it?
Because I think one of the
things I think a lot of people
who are watching have to
understand, it's super okay
to be in a transition
where you love your craft,
it was a small business,
you're good at your craft
whether that's buying,
by the way being a lawyer
or doing a landscaping business,
or selling baseball cards,
and that when it grows
it now becomes about people management.
And for a lot of people
that are artists or good
at their craft, there's a, I'll
tell you AJ's biggest issue
in the growth of Vayner was
the unbelievable non-enjoyment
of managing people.
- Yeah, managing people, yeah.
- Are you saying that you don't like it?
The early tastes of it?
Or you're scared to fuck it up?
Or what?
- [Nathan] Oh no, I love what I do.
I haven't set my alarm
for the past two years.
- No, no, I mean, are you,
do you not like the idea
of managing people.
- [Nathan] That's right.
I can subsidize hate it,
it's just like anything else,
I'm just starting out and I
wouldn't say I'm very good
at it right now, learning it as I go.
- When you say you're not good,
what mistakes do you think
you've made?
Say it out loud because
putting it out there
is a very important thing.
- A relief too.
- It will help you.
What mistakes do you think you've made?
- [Nathan] Um, well early
on when I gave trust
to an employee, when
I (telephone static)--
- Hey brother, hold on, hold on.
It's a little muffled,
that's why I thought you had
a sports bar and not
a baseball card store.
One more time?
What was it?
- [Nathan] Early on, I had
an employee that I had given
quite a bit of trust to--
- Trust.
- And when I saw that
trust was being violated,
I didn't necessarily--
- Fire.
- [Nathan] Immediately.
- Yeah yeah, fire.
But we might have--
- We commiserate about this
all the time.
There's a nice cliche that
nobody actually follows
which is hire slow and fire fast.
So, this mistake that
you're making is a mistake
that Gary and I made, I'm making it--
- I hire extremely fast and fire slow.
- Exactly, and by the way
agonize it, and as you should.
These are human--
- Nathan, let me say something.
When people make fun of me or critique me
or when we're intercepted--
- We make fun of each other.
- Exactly, I make fun of myself.
When I do that, there is
one thing that I think
as a small business you
will appreciate this.
Brother, let me give you a
humongous piece of advice,
and this is for everybody.
You have to sleep at night.
I am thrilled to give up
money everyday of my life
to feel better when I go to sleep.
Now, that makes me not as
good of an entrepreneur
as I could be, 'cause
when you're on the field
you're on the field,
like, it is what it is.
But, don't over-judge yourself either.
And you're going through an evolution.
I mean, to me, there's
nothing wrong with you trying
to find your patterns on how
to fire somebody quicker.
- And, dirty little secret, Nathan?
Every single entrepreneur
and leader goes through
the transition that you're talking about.
And the biggest lament is
that they didn't act sooner
when they already knew
because it takes time to get
used to that.
But so I would just say, but
no body talks about that.
Everybody talks a big
game, like ah, I mean,
I dealt with my staff issues right away.
Nobody does.
So, if that's your biggest
issue you're doing great.
- What else have you fucked up though?
- [Nathan] Oh man, there's
been plenty of them.
- This is cathartic.
- Let me ask you a question,
what are you most worried
about going into next year
as you continue to grow?
Because I think you know I'm
about to make sports cards
very culturally popular
in 2019, and all of you
are gonna benefit from it.
So you're probably gonna
do more revenue next year.
- [Nathan] Ah, I know man.
I really appreciate the
help too, I really do.
- Not great news at all.
- The biggest thing
that I fear is, we've built
this big, well, what I consider
a industry, and for whatever reason,
I have this fear that one
day after I'm long gone
and there's not 500 people
watching and it just goes away,
whether that's, or whatever.
- He's, so, Matt, let me
have everybody's watching.
What he's done, there's a big
thing called pack breaking
which is people, basically,
people buy slots in boxes
of cards where you get the
third pack that he opens live
on Facebook or whatever live
platform, and you can call it
a form of gambling, and form of contests.
But like, literally, for example,
there's a famous one that he didn't do,
and he's doing a great
job, I've seen some of his.
But, 86, 87 Fleeter
with the Jordan rookie?
People pay $2000 a pack,
and then if you get a Jordan
or in his world, like, what's
the most expensive pack
break you've done brother?
- I mean, we've done
$1500 live on Free Space,
we open four or five lives a night.
So I mean, $1500 plus
the box, stuff like that.
- Yeah, so like, and in
that box, how many packs
are in there?
- [Nathan] Well, there's
only 10 individual cards--
- Right, and so you sold
the slots of the cards.
So it even goes down into the,
so you sold, so it was a
1500 box, and how much,
I just want to teach everybody
about this whole business,
and you sold the individual
cards in the pack.
Like, the first card Matt Higgins bought,
I bought the third card from the pack.
How much was the slot, how much
did you sell the slots for?
- [Nathan] If it's 1500
retail, like to sale a box
for 1500, if it's at a
group rate, we might charge,
I think around 64 times,
make around 150 bucks
for past--
- Well, I never had brilliance in society.
- Oh, it's super brilliant.
It's also super entertaining to watch.
Because the thrill.
I watch, I'm not even in it--
- [Matt] No, I wanna do it.
- It's like watching sports.
I watch pack breaks that
I'm not even in just waiting
for the big card to be
like, or the big card
to come out of the pack.
- So Nathan, let me ask you a question.
So if people stopped caring
to watch you do this,
why would they stop caring?
When you, when it keeps you up at night?
- Nathan, you said one example.
Let me give you a headline.
If a war breaks out, you're
not gonna give a fuck
about your pack break business.
(Nathan chuckling)
Like, I love when people
like Gary, I worry a war
breaks out.
I'm like if a war breaks
out in our country,
you're gonna be running to the bunkers.
Like, I don't think like, you know.
The last thing you're gonna
be thinking about like fuck,
man, there's a war going
on, New York just blew up,
I don't think 500 people
are gonna tune into my pack
break tonight.
Good news.
Like, going back to
9/11, everything stopped.
Like, if a war breaks out,
that's gonna be the last
fucking eternity scenario.
(men arguing)
- [Matt] Just keep going.
(men laughing)
I assume there's other
things other than war
that you're worried about.
- [Nathan] I mean, really, not much--
- Okay wait, so then, what I
hear is you have the typical
paranoia of a founder and a
business owner who is worried
it's all, I still grapple
with whether or not I made it
or not.
I mean--
- Matt, Matt, hate to,
real quick to interrupt,
I'll give you a perfect example.
On the flight from LA this
morning, I had, I texted
a client of ours.
We have a thing at VaynerMedia
called Vayner Mentors
for Small Businesses.
It's kinda like being a McKenzie.
You pay one hundred, two
hundred, three hundred thousand
dollars for a project where
we give you business advice,
marketing advice to take your
business to the next level.
An incredible young woman out
of Florida with a furniture
store used us, it's been rolling,
everything's going great,
and then this hurricane just hit her.
- [Matt] Right.
- So like, it's real too.
We can joke about war.
It could be a hurricane.
Tennessee, I mean like, I have
a whole thesis of earthquakes
in Tennessee, like you might
get hit by an earthquake,
Nathan.
- And Nathan, the fact that
you're worried about this now,
doing five million a
year in a brilliant idea
is why you're gonna be at
10 million dollars a year.
So, don't lament the fact
that you have this paranoia--
- Nathan, I'll tell you
what I'm worried about
with your business is that
what you're winning on
is you're a first mover
in it, just like I was
in social media.
Like, if cards continue to
get as popular as I think
they're going to, there's
gonna be a lot of other people
breaking packs, and you're
gonna have more competition.
So you need to find another
way the way you found this
to sell sports cards.
The hardest thing for people
to do is put themselves
out of business.
I think the thing that
I've always done well,
which is why I don't
always kick the most profit
but I always build very
big businesses and I'll win
in the end is whatever's
working for me, I start creating
other things that could work for me
because I don't want to
be reliant on one move.
Pack breaking is your move
right now, you need to triple
down on that to go to ten
as the same token you need
to start creating--
- Let's do it for storage
units so I can watch it on TV.
But like, I'd buy into that.
- But Nathan, you need to
start coming up with something
else like regional shows
or like a podcast or like
an event once a month in
your store, physically,
that people will want to travel
to from around the country
because who the fuck knows
there's a way to get a $10000
card like if I win X.
You're gonna need to add other sizzles.
What you're about to do is fall
in love with the one sizzle
that got you there, which
then makes you vulnerable
long term.
Do you understand?
- [Nathan] Yes, yes.
We do do all that, Gary.6
We do trade nights once
a month, we do like,
I'm always listening to what you say.
Content, content, content.
So I'll do--
- Good.
- I do kids videos--
- [Nathan] We do Kids
Collectors Club every month.
- Good.
- [Nathan] We do what's
it worth Wednesday--
- What are you doing,
you know the other thing
you can do is maybe take some
of the money you're making
now which is different
than the kind of money
you made before, and maybe
you can find the comic book
version of you and get into,
or the toy version of you,
and maybe own 50% of a comic book store
and teach her or him your
model and watch her com,
you know, buy into her
comic book store that's only
doing 800 thousand in revenue this year.
Be the infrastructure for
her to do four million
on the same concept you came up with.
You see where I'm going?
- [Nathan] Yes, yes.
- Diversify.
- Hey, before you go, I
don't think you said what his
business was, did he?
- [Gary] The name we can find him?
Yeah, yeah.
- Give him a little plug.
- [Nathan] Grand Slam Collectibles
in Murfreesboro, Tennessee.
- Alright, I'm gonna check it out.
- Grand Slam Collectibles.
- [Nathan] I really
appreciate both of ya'll.
Ya'll are both an inspiration
to the red service man,
ya'll keep Jets flying, alright?
- Are you gonna be watching Shark Tank?
Matt, what episode, do
we have a sense of this?
- Sunday, October 21st at 9pm Eastern.
- Sunday, October 21st 9pm.
Sunday, October 21st 9pm.
I expect the Vayner
Nation to have massive--
- It's gonna be one of the
best episodes they've ever had,
it's a very heart wrenching
story, so tune in.
It'll be a special night.
- Is it when the guest shark
was terrible and they had to
kick him off the set?
- That's part of it, but
they edited that out.
(men laughing)
- Alright Nathan, thank you.
- [Matt] Take care.
- Matt, October 21st, 9pm.
I want everybody right now to
go into their Google Calendar,
set alerts, I want viewing
parties, I want them to see
such a weird spike in Nielsen ratings,
that they can only give
credit to Matt Higgins
so that he becomes a permanent,
or whatever the hell he wants.
I have no idea what he wants.
- And in Instagram too, right?
- You're very hot now on,
it's been fun to watch you
get serious about your--
- You know why I like Instagram?
Because I--
- Tell me.
- Because you have to earn it.
It can't be hacked.
It doesn't go viral.
You have to work.
I like that.
I have to engage people, you have to talk.
It's very organic and natural.
I love that.
Like, you have to put in the effort.
- Well, all of them are like that, really.
- But I feel like Twitter,
things can go viral.
I don't know.
Instagram, to me at least, feels like--
- Things can go viral,
you just haven't put out
viral content.
- Whatever, whatever.
So maybe you're not teaching me.
Do I not owe in a big piece
of the biggest digital?
There are a thousand people
there and nobody helps me.
- Yes, but listen.
Michael Jordan had two
children that wanted to play
basketball, too.
(men chuckling)
So sometimes it comes--
- That's wrong.
You know I lost the weight--
- You know why I like--
- Lose the weight because of this show.
No, no, 'cause you told me
if you don't lose weight
by January 1st, I'm gonna
mercifully make fun of you.
- [Gary] That's true.
- Remember, you did that.
You said you were so fat--
- That's so true.
I really knew you had it in you.
- I did.
How much did I lose?
- [Gary] I don't know, tell us!
- 50 pounds.
- [Gary] It looks great.
- That's what happens if you
don't eat carbs for a year
and you just fill yourself
on Ketosis, thank you.
- What do you want to
leave everybody here with?
We're wrapping up now.
What should the, we
have an entrepreneurial
kind of crowd watching right now.
Like, what should, what's a great tid bit
or something unique or because
so many of them watch me,
what's something that people
don't, we reference earlier
I'm smart and see the puck.
But I think people know that.
Like, what's an insight to
me or Chang or somebody else,
like what could be a tidbit
of what people are not
thinking about from your perspective.
- Well one, about you,
you are what you see.
Which I love about you.
Everything that you put out
is the same thing that I get
when I have our cup of coffee,
so it's a credit to you.
That empathy is so important.
Like, everybody I back
who's been successful
has deep soulful empathy.
So, along your way, Nathan
was struggling with the fact
that he's not maybe firing
as fast and maybe he's
grappling with it?
- Yeah, yeah.
- That's probably a
by-product of his empathy.
- [Gary] 100%.
- Hearing his voice?
Keep your empathy.
You can get to the top
while preserving it.
And, for me--
- Do you think money
and fame expose people
or change that?
- I always say the stone to my wife.
I want money and power in
autonomy so I can be more
of who I am rather than less.
- Couldn't agree more.
- [Matt] I think all it does is reveal.
- I want to stay in a place
of that 16 year old kid
who felt powerless, and I
want to use money and power
and everything else to inspire
and eventually redistribute,
make a difference.
And so, that's who I
was before Shark Tank,
that's who I'll be, I'll
be more of that after.
- Matt, question--
- You haven't changed.
You haven't changed from the bagel store.
Like, you don't roll
around think I'm Gary Vee.
I mean, you're, can't walk
two feet without people
stopping, which is very
irritating, by the way.
But you seem to be okay with it.
I would never want it.
- I think, I'll be honest
with you, I think if anything,
I've become, I've only,
I've gone the other way.
Like, I'm just desperately,
like to me it would be,
I would die if somebody
thought that I changed.
- Gary and I talk about
this topic all the time.
I don't know if this can
be totally cultivated.
You were born with the ability
to truly love and listen
to yourself and block out the hate.
Which, I admire that.
We have this deep soulful conversations.
I've taken much more of the
criticism, you always say
play more defense, it's
just sort of how I'm wired.
But, what you have is magical.
Like, encouraging people to
just trust that inner voice
and self love, like, that is the key.
I don't know where it came from with you,
I guess it's in the factory settings?
- I think my mom is a beast, a beast.
And also look, you know, maybe we should,
I was listening to your story carefully.
Like, it was really great
for me to be an immigrant,
a terrible student, not good at sports.
My entire foundation of
my youth was adversity
and people telling me I wasn't.
Thus, I didn't grow up
in an environment looking
for anybody's reinforcement.
Like, all I needed was myself,
you know, I needed my mom
to a degree.
And then I was old enough
that that became me,
and so at some level, I
just, here's my big thing.
You're this thing from me,
like thing about our conversations,
I'm just not interested
in the people that boo
in the second quarter.
(Matt chuckling)
Like for me, this is my
thinking on judgment or hate
along the way.
If those people are right
when it goes to triple zero
of the game, then I have
to concede that truth.
If they were right that
I was full of shit,
not as smart as I think,
like, whatever it may be,
and it ends, I've had my career
and I was not successful,
I over-leveraged, I went to zero,
I had to work for somebody
one day, I would just,
you know, I don't like
shaking people's hands
after you lose a game of basketball.
But I do it because I lost.
And that's the facts.
- But that capacity to
do that is super human.
- But I mean--
- I don't know where
it comes from.
- But I don't think it has to be.
And that's why I'm trying to bring more,
like it's actually practical.
It's the same reason
that I don't get excited.
The Jets were beating the
Browns 14 nothing at half time
the other day.
We lost.
Like, just 'cause I'm winning,
like back to what Nathan
was worried about,
just 'cause I'm conceivably
winning right this minute?
Everything could start
going downhill tomorrow.
And if it does?
Then I lost.
And it goes in a lot of ways.
It not only goes professionally,
and this is where I don't
think people are being thoughtful.
I don't just score on the money part.
A lot of people that boo us along the way
are just talking about money, right?
Matt Lowers brand looks different today
than it did a year-and-a-half ago.
He was making 20 plus
million, 30 million last year.
So to me, back to the empathy thing?
I'm going, I know it, you know
this way better than most.
Very few people know it as well as you do.
I will always leave economics on the table
because I don't believe being
the greatest entrepreneur
of this generation is just the person
that made the most money.
Like, the reason I think
I can beat Zux and Elon
and Sarah Blakely and
others is 'cause for me,
and I get to judge 'cause that's my life,
the greatest entrepreneur of
this generation is not only
somebody, and I do think
you have to succeed,
I do think I have to make
lots of money 'cause that's
the game of an entrepreneur,
but the one who brings the most
value to the entrepreneurial
space, yeah, that's interesting to me.
- I mean, you put something
out the other day.
Your post, I forgot how you worded it,
but you said focus on what you do well
because other people focus on
what you're not doing well.
- [Gary] That's right.
- Well, it's interesting,
but a lot of people
take the opposite approach.
I gotta mitigate my downside.
I gotta work at what I'm not good at--
- Because they--
- [Matt] You're all into that.
- I'll tell you why.
'Cause they don't realize
that whoever they're scared
is in control of them is not
as in control as they think.
The Board of Directors, the
CEO, the 51% equity partner.
Yes, in the micro of the
moment, definitely not.
In the macro of life.
- Alright.
- Question of the day.
Every guest gets to ask
the question of the day.
So what question, do you Matt,
have for the Veyner nation?
This is an amazing opportunity
for you to get some insights.
- So explain it a little more.
- Well, I'm thrilled to know
you don't watch the show
at all--
(Matt laughing)
When I have a guest, when
I have a guest he or she
gets to ask a question and
then thousands of comments
come on Facebook and
YouTube, and some guests
ask silly things like
what's your favorite color.
Others are very strategic 'cause
they're trying to actually
literally get an insight at
that moment of like a trend
or a thing.
Or then some people are
trying to scratch to itch
on some opinions that they're
debating on themselves
right now.
- Okay.
- So what's your question.
- Alright, what's a product
that I don't know about
that you think I should know
about that is going to be
massive that's not on the radar right now?
- I like that.
- So I can buy it and
help make Gary richer.
(Gary laughing)
- Thank you, brother.
Thanks for being on the show.
- Thanks.
- You keep asking questions.
We'll keep answering them.
(exciting rhythmic music)